means and his big title came out man
it's a big title
title what was that
yeah so uh Zelda tears of the king that
came out I got got a couple hours into
it not really had enough time to like
really really jump into it but
I could see like drastic improvements
from the previous game you know they
kind of took the sandbox from the
original one and they're like look we
know you like this and they saw all the
crazy stuff people were doing with that
game yeah and they're like we're just
gonna give you more tools and give you a
story to to do hey I'll actually say I
was surprised like going into the game
uh there there's more narrative it looks
like in this game over the whole rest of
the wild gotta stop you right there for
a second I'm glad you said that
this is where I will bend the needle I
did like the introduction and the story
and the way it's being presented I that
was my main issue of everything I seen
prior in that early trailer but I have
to give the like that part this is what
I'm talking about just just tell me why
I'm doing this explain it make it
interesting make it cool I want to find
out about this civilization all that but
I had to get those balls off because you
got I really get a chance to play too
long so I'm trying to get mines in now
because I know you're about to get in
depth but thank you for saying that
because that's what gripped me in
initially so salute to see I'm not
Nintendo see switch company updates I
give credit what credit is due continue
yeah so it's kind of crazy the the
mechanics they put in this game
um I haven't really dove into it too
much I will say the tutorial island is a
little like confusing if you don't
really sit and look I missed a shrine
like I literally passed a shrine because
you need three shrines to do the
beginning it's like the tutorial three
shrines and I did the first and the
third one and missed the second one
because I didn't know it was there
salute so you know I like I like the
stuff they're doing
um I really like the Ascend ability it
gives
after since I missed the second one I
had to go through all of them again but
the good thing is I had that Ascend
ability so I could just go through the
mountain instead of going around the
mountain so that ability is really
transformative moving you around it it
completely changes the gameplay it's
it's really nice to be able to walk up
and know that okay can I actually get
above this by climbing but you don't
like in the original one it's like this
that do I have enough stamina to make
that job to make that climb but I know
now on this one it's like I just go
below it if there's like a little area
where I can go through I just Ascend
above it all
no doubt no doubt so again I did a
couple questions I did have for you um I
know you're still kind of early uh one
feedback I heard two couple feedback I
heard was um somebody said chores of the
Kingdom like they have you running
around doing a bunch of stuff do you
feel like that was in the game a bit or
you feel that maybe overblown for what
you play so far
uh so far I do see what they're talking
about well I think what they're
referring to is there's a lot of
tutorial things they they go into very
big detail on you know if you didn't
play breath of the wild we're going to
teach you how to play those mechanics
and we have all these new Mechanics for
teasers of the kingdom and we're going
to really teach you how to do that
because there's building in this in this
game like you could build uh
just about anything you can really think
of I saw someone have like a cart full
of barrels and what they did is they
went on their horse
and they jumped off the horse went
through like an enemy camp and he shot
the barrels I think he killed the horse
but but he blew up like all the enemies
in the middle of it so the creativity of
the sandbox is insane because they saw
how much stuff people was doing in the
original breath of the wild and I think
the core team was like people like what
we're doing they just don't like the
fact that there's no dungeons I haven't
hit a dungeon yet I heard the dungeons
is off the chain yeah so they're like
we're gonna give you guys the dungeons
back and make it feel like more Zelda
we're going to put a little bit more of
a narrative focus on it because I do
feel like there's more narrative focus
and then I can work I've already come
across three cut scenes called story yes
three holes wait wait hold on we do we
do we doing narrative
yeah okay okay I feel like there's a lot
more voice acting in this game too yeah
than there was in the other one okay uh
though it's kind of like my cheesy story
though Zelda's missing
What salute to them Incorporated like
like
what I like about this one is in the
original one Zelda was in the main
dungeon holding Ganon
and this one you don't even know where
Zelda is like like you go there and like
it it's it's a good game I
all I know got that energy got that feel
dude what other questions you have I got
um so that we got a dungeon what about
one of the two criticisms for breath of
the wild was obviously this big Kai
would go back and forth with this weapon
breaking right how do you feel about
that with the with creativity and then
the other thing that people felt and I I
didn't feel this way but a lot of people
felt was that breath of the wild for his
the open world aspect that it was they
felt it was too open there's not a lot
to do in between things and baron like a
density problem do you feel won the
weapon stuff and two the density of the
world do you think they have addressed
that so I think the density of the world
still an issue to a point but at the
same time
I would say if you go back to like the
old Viking days like it's gonna look
similar you're gonna have vast majority
of areas not occupied by really anyone
and you're gonna have people doing
patrols like you see this in in tears of
the Kingdom I don't really I don't
really hit them for that too much
because I think that is more realistic
than people act but I do think the world
feels more alive than it did in breath
of the wild sometimes I'll be going
seeing a fox just walk running around
seeing these random horses going
obviously that was in breath of the wild
but it just it feels like they took that
foundation and they didn't break it they
just built on and you know one thing I
uh as far as like the weapon breaking
it's like look if you got a sword and
it's about to break combine over rock
you know and
I don't know the extent you confuse
stuff yet okay but I'm very interested
to see it like you confuse certain items
and make fire arrows and stuff now
so I I think I think they got something
I do